America loves a comeback budlight
looking for Redemption after their
ill-fated partnership with transgender
influencer Dylan it caused a consumer
Revolt which tanked the stock and beer
sales the light now trying to do what's
right to win back customers ditch the
woke and go back to being funny and
patriotic check out their expensive star
studded Super Bowl ad I wish I was at
that
fight he's going to need another bicep
house party definitely let's go
you wish for a T-Rex guilty let's go to
Super Bowl 58 now we're
talking and Trump says it's time to give
budlight a break the former president
posting on Truth social and saying that
while the Mulan stun a mistake of Epic
Proportions Bud Light has paid the price
and perhaps deserves a second chance
judge
Janine one of the most effective
boycotts ever budlight should we let
budlight transition back into a
man oh I like the way you put that um
but it's a horse isn't it a cly that's
right you're right uh here's the thing
you know there's no question that enh
Houser bush is a company that employs a
lot of Americans you know uh they have
put out U media over the years that is
very you know heartwarming especially
during the holidays but budlight put
itself in this mess okay budlight made a
choice on an issue that was n that
important were they not happy enough
with us you know with those of us who
love the red white and blue and are all
American and women who don't want
competing with them I mean you
know they they put themselves in this
war forgiveness and Redemption is part
of all of our lives and I think it's
important but I got to tell you it's
going to be very hard for me to go back
because I have very bad and I'm a Beer
Drinker by the way I started drinking
paps Blue Ribbon years ago we are let's
go yeah um um so I mean I love beer but
you know okay Kavanaugh that's it do you
are you a Bud Light person or were you I
am not a Beer Drinker okay so not a Beer
Drinker but would you forgive in this
situation what bothers me most is that
they made the mistake of combining
politics and social issues with business
I think the most frustrating thing for
us is that more and more Americans see
businesses doing this getting involved
in areas that should be left to
politicians rather than just focusing on
providing a good product and good
service that's that's what I hope that
more of these businesses actually do so
that we as consumers don't have to think
about oh well is this a woke business or
an anti-woke business is this MAA or is
it antia just provide good service and a
good product compete fairly whether it's
here at home or with businesses around
the world uh and and leave all the
politics of the politicians when a man
wrongs you Dana and comes crawling back
on his hands never forget hands his
knees so don't for but light is saying
okay I'm sorry here I'll give you
everything no how about what you donate
to my campaign that's that might be
something I ask I look I think they're
making a decision in order to get back
and I like that um you think about
Gillette with toxic masculinity they've
never tried to apologize for that or
come back and Peter to this day will not
buy anything from that company and he
holds that Grudge very tight the earned
media that this ad is getting is worth
maybe a hundred times more than what
they had to pay to get this done so I
would think from a strategy standpoint
from a Communications Point hats off to
them and I don't drink beer anymore but
I used to love a PBR judge yeah yes all
right you remember they hired that woman
that ran this campaign ran it into the
ground it's her fault she's gone she's
gone she's gone I mean you have to
remind yourself that we won wokeism is
dead when you see this Swift response
and I think budlight does deserve a
second chance because there are 177,000
employees there who are a lot like us
they had no control over that decision
so why punish them because of one lady
that one lady did that and when you're
seeing the sharp turn that bud is taking
with UFC and with the comedian Shane
Gillis you couldn't get further away
from Dylan milany If you hired the
Hell's Angels so they're sending a clear
message which is Dad's home and he's
pissed and don't ever mess with my Bud
Light again the message that budlight is
sending is all sending it to themselves
not just us and we've a lot of companies
have learned from this Bud Light Fiasco
one you go broke insulting your audience
ccnn right you go broke listening to
Twitter activists who never never use
your product especially beer and their
ideas are delusional and begging for
attention and yet and you're stupid for
listening to anybody born after 1990 who
take that crap seriously it's it's not
on the audience it's not the audience
fault they weren't trans phobes they
didn't like Dylan mulany because she was
annoying she was pretentious had nothing
to do with her being trans and you also
finally go broke using a spokesperson
least likely to use your product you got
Dylan mulany a trans influencer where
does that draw from what Market there's
only one you know it it was just a huge
mistake Shane Gillis on the other hand
is a great choice he looks like he
spoons with a 30
pack very good all right so is going to
be drinking a Bud Light before his Super
Bowl interview with Donald Trump
probably not probably not maybe after
coming up Taylor Swift is going to war
with a college student hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else